se extienden los reclamos de los
manifestantes en colombia a las
agridulces celebraciones por la retirada
del proyecto de reforma tributaria del
presidente iván duque los colombianos
continúan en las calles unas marchas a
las que se han unido el sector del
transporte y la minga indígena desde
cali y es que son más de 100 las
demandas originales de los sindicatos y
el comité del paro nacional del 28 de
abril lo esperábamos pero realmente no
quedamos tranquilos no sabemos que pase
no sabemos que otra propuesta tenga no
sabemos y que otro nombre se le dé a
esta situación nos preocupa el tema de
la reforma de la salud
nos preocupan muchas otras cosas más que
todavía no están contemplados en este
cambio el descontento con la clase
política dirigente comenzó a fluir en
todo el país con las masivas marchas de
2019 que perdieron fuerza por la
pandemia
las peticiones sobrepasan el ámbito
económico miles de colombianos piden la
renuncia del ejecutivo así como la
retirada de la reforma de la salud que
prevé mayores privatizaciones
a otras personas ya una se unan a la
lucha que
que sigan adelante que pongamos
resistencia a ver si tumbamos a este
gobierno
gloria hasta concluir la implementación
de los acuerdos de paz y el reparto de
la riqueza en uno de los países donde la
desigualdad estructural aumenta cada año
son otras de las exigencias que resuenan
en las protestas frente a la respuesta
de la fuerza pública a los grupos de
derechos y la sociedad civil piden una
reforma policial inmediata la
desmilitarización de las ciudades y
justicia para las decenas de víctimas
el presidente de duke debe asumir la
responsabilidad de haber presentado una
reforma fiscal sin consenso y luego de
haber dirigido el aparato policial y
militar para reprimir a los
manifestantes la inexperiencia e
ineptitud del presidente está llevando
al país al desastre en los últimos días
las protestas han derivado en una
escalada de la brutalidad de la fuerza
pública contra los manifestantes en su
mayoría pacíficos